will you support the deal
I can only say this that the prime
minister is on the cusp of securing a
really fantastic result for everyone
involved
thank you
well the broad smile from Steve Baker
there and that that is really
significant I think because as well as
the dup in Northern Ireland the Prime
Minister has to can Vince eurosceptic
back benches within his own party that
this deal is the right deal to get their
support Steve Baker speaks for many of
them he was chair of the ERG the
European research group the eurosceptic
group of conservatives within Parliament
and it does seem that from what he has
been told clearly from that visit to
number 10 pleases him uh he's saying
that the prime minister is on the cusp
of a great deal